presse ouvrant les yeux comment être un
grand mouvement gâchée à cause de ça
mais pas seulement parce que les gens ne
seraient responsables et aussi parce que
c'est une stratégie de la police en fait
d'emmener les gens sur le terrain de la
police pour plus parler des sujets de
fond mais que dans lequel on s'est un
peu laissé enfermer j'ai été très frappé
par le fait qu'au début la question des
gilets jaunes le sim de rufin on avait
parlé c'est la question de la fin c'est
la question de la sélection de la santé
cinq sens du déplacement c'est la
question de la misère vraiment la misère
misère et ça c'était quand même langer
d'une insurrection extrêmement puissante
et de ce point de vue extrêmement à
gauche qui s'était produit dès novembre
des descentes mais petit à petit la
question de la répression policière qui
a été réellement il ya eu des
mutilations il ya déjà arrachés ça a été
vraiment sanglant est extrêmement grave
a occupé une place démesurée enfin tout
à fait fondamental dans le traitement
d'un gilet jaune et à la fin on avait
l'impression que quand il ya une
manifestation d'un gilet jaune le seul
sujet c'était que qui a été tabassé
comment on a été tabassé qu'est ce qui a
été produit comme forme de répression et
on a complètement oublié leurs
revendications substantielles qui est le
principe des gels et je ne le connais
pas je le dis être tabassés pendant une
manifestation prend le risque d'être
mutilée prendre le risque d'avoir une
main arrachée c'est un pur scandale et
c'est une honte de la part de l'état et
ne s'était passé sous le maquereau nice
mais il faut absolument de dénoncer mais
en même temps et une certaine manière
d'avoir transformé ce sujet comme étant
le sujet majeur en vérité des choses que
c'était un mouvement qui était seulement
confrontés à la question de la police
qui fait qu'on a oublié totalement de
paris les enjeux sociaux politiques
socio-économiques et son fondement d'un
tel mouvement et qui à mon avis font
partie d'une opération de diversion dont
le pouvoir est tout à fait conscient en
nous emmenant sur le terrain de la prise
pour plus que nous parlons des systèmes
et des questions économiques ou sociaux
social de base et donc il faut se voilà
typiquement un cadre d'un puissant c'est
à dire c'est la manière dont croyant
faire quelque chose on est en train de
s'autodétruire
hélas en croyant qu'on a fait monter
monter monter un sujet sur la violence
policière
est ce qu'on n'a pas en quelque sorte
perdu le contact avec la seule version
authentique que porter le gilet jaune je
dis ça sans du tout condamné la question
de la réflexion sur la police j'ai écrit
un livre à kassa traoré le combat damas
je pense qu'il ya des luttes dont la
question centrale est la question
policière notamment dans les quartiers
populaires et le traitement des jeunes
verts sont noirs et arabes où la
question carcérale mais en même temps
dans d'autres types de mouvements
quand la question policière devient plus
important que la question de fond alors
à mon avis une défaite du mouvement
[Musique]